there's there's nobody else
because I don't think guys his whole I'm
gonna go in there and end everything is
the right way to create a new better
world really are that actually surprises
me that that's your position if I burned
it all down we'd all die in a horrible
fire like what's the value
come on come on saying we want to weed
out corruption it's not the same as
destroy the city yeah but he's like I'm
gonna go fire I'm gonna go obliterate
the Deep State it's the most vague uh
nonsensical statement like what does he
mean he's going to issue with pink slips
and they're just gonna say okay no
schedule F as as he already implemented
in his first term and then did not win
re-election so was not able to carry out
and then Biden I think was I think it
was the bite Administration that
reversed it was the
basically he was setting the policy for
we are going to fire people who have
been permanently in government and who
should not be here anymore the idea that
you can get hired by the federal
government be bad at your job be corrupt
and not get fired is insane so when he
implements schedule F he then says if I
get reelected we're going to bring back
schedule F and start firing these
corrupt individuals why would your
position be that's bad because he's
talking about people that just got hired
six weeks ago he's going to fire them
but he's but but he's literally
forever
that would be complete Insanity he'd
disband the federal government like what
why is it incentive that's what they did
to the Iraqis after the Gulf War and it
created uh they are targeting us Ian
they are targeting you you are but hold
on hold on hold on going from there are
permanent bureaucrats who should be
fired to your statement Ian he's going
to shut down the whole government that's
not what that no the Deep state is the
same kind of uh tautology that got
Kennedy killed I I believe tautology is
the right word I'm going to look up the
definition you can't I mean if you just
say it's everything and they're all like
yeah tautology is like Love Is Love
right it's when you just like exactly
when Donald Trump
When Donald Trump spends years and and
other uh advisors and individuals in his
Circle spend years describing what is
called as the permanent government
individuals who work in the federal
government who have been there
throughout multiple administrations who
set policy and need to be fired for
wrongdoing that's what he has explained
over and over again and then he says
we've got to fire these people
colloquially they're called The Deep
state
so I think you just didn't know about
heads of agencies are you talking about
every employee what do you mean there
are people who have been some some are
uh in charge some were even uh he
mistakenly hired some you know he made
he made big mistakes in that regard but
we're not talking about going to the
entirety of a single agency and
literally just firing every single
person and then leaving an empty room
he's saying there are people who need to
be fired who can't be fired but he's
like imagine if you bought a pizza
restaurant and everybody in there was
sitting around and nobody was working
and you're like why am I paying you
people like Union contract you can't
fire us and so then some guy's like okay
well I'm gonna buy this pizza place and
then I'm sending a new policy I'm gonna
negotiate a new contract and say I can
fire if you don't do your job so then
the people who work there all team up
conspire accuse you of crimes and have
you arrested
Ian have you ever lived through a
government shutdown yes because you have
because you're yeah
no no no like a government shutdown at
the end of the year when when they don't
meet the Appropriations bills right and
they only have essential people working
right from the federal government you
don't notice it you don't feel it at all
a day in your life they could cut all of
those people if you are non-essential if
you're a non-essential worker and you
get laid off during a government
shutdown I'm sorry goodbye but that's
that's a that's a fiscal argument that's
like we're wasting so much money on
people well I I'm just saying you're
right on top of that I mean like you're
not going to feel it all if all of these
leeches and these corrupt people the
people that are not implementing the
president's policy because they don't
like him
are are still in power or because that's
what they are I mean if he if he puts
out a policy and they say we're going to
slow walk this we're not going to
implement it then then they do actually
have power they're not elected they need
to go they need to go all of them need
to go
well I'm open to that but having a
president do it with the authoritarian
Zeal is like wait wait yo legislate that
let Congress do that why but but they're
going after they're different branches
of government no no no stop stop it's a
different branch of governments Congress
is one branch there is the judicial
branch and there's the executive branch
Donald Trump would be the head of the
executive branch Congress is not going
to go and fire staff for which they are
not involved a different branch of
government the separation of powers
exist for a reason well are you so that
we don't have dictators but going and
destroying branches if I was gonna your
pizza shop metaphors
his branch of government and saying bad
people should be fired is exactly he
said I'm going to obliterate the Deep
State and that means he's gonna in the
executive nullify the FBI there will be
no FBI effect that's the executive
branch are you saying fire that people
that work there that hire new people in
what do you say you are being willfully
obtused what do you think the Deep state
is just out of curiosity like how would
you define the Deep State because I feel
like that's where we're all a little did
bureaucratic officials with nefarious
intentions no no I don't know what
they're okay well see this is where you
are making things up and if you don't
understand what is being said you can
answer the question I'm not making it
that's not how I Define the Deep State
officials how is that you define it so
the permanent government so we can go
back to the hearings that actually took
place when they had NSA officials and
they discussed does the Deep says exist
and they said no it doesn't and people
in the media ran articles saying there
is no deep State they then said we call
it the permanent government these are
certain elements within certain
departments who have been here
throughout multiple administrations and
set policies they are unelected in many
instances some of these people have
committed overt violations of either uh
law like the Hatch Act for instance
which seems to get violated a lot or
just in general they did things that
weren't firing
so when when for years we're having a
discussion about people who for some
reason can't be fired and should be
fired and then Donald Trump comes along
and says that guy needs to be fired we
go yeah he's right you then say no the
Deep State means something totally
different than my assumption give me
names Don if you're gonna fire people
tell me who you're gonna fire I don't
want to hear that you're going to
obliterate the government that doesn't
happen obliterate the Deep State it's
obliterate the FBI the CIA the NSA like
send them to there is none anymore
that's what that term you're
obliterating the the people that are
obstructionary in there from
implementing his policy the people that
have been unelected that have been
targeting him that have been targeting
conservatives like in the IRS right when
you can't when they're targeting
turkishes and and conservative 501c3's
just because they have the name Patriot
in it those people are the deep deep
State that's who they are they are the
obstructive people who hate us they hate
you for not even paying like for not
following their line they don't like us
I think that's a dirty tactics you tell
people that they're hated by other
people you don't know and you're gonna
think I know them they don't know me
you're an authoritarian you have hard
authoritarian Tendencies let me ask you
a question when Donald Trump tried to
pull all of our troops out of Syria was
that a good thing
uh at face value yeah that war was
ridiculous and it wasn't a war was it
was it good when there was a uh uh
officials who lied to Donald Trump to
keep troops in Syria no man but these
are these are real pointers
what was going on I don't know if it
would have killed a bunch of people if
they'd pulled out I don't know what the
situation was there right but it's
Advanced value if the president issues
an order and it's violated there's a big
problem in the chain of command that
person should be reprimanded should they
be fired for lying to the president and
the American people to keep military
activity ongoing in a country we did not
declare potentially yeah if you're a
commander and one of your dudes goes out
and to violate one of your orders you
may not fire him because there may be
some you know rudimentary justification
there was there was a while ago I
referred to you as the banality of evil
and this is a really good example of
that see for in my world and I wonder if
you guys agree with me and the people
listening agree if there is a
commander-in-chief who has been duly
elected by the people of his of his
country
to properly lead and serve out his term
as the commander-in-chief of the Armed
Forces and he says
I order my troops to be removed and then
tells the American people we are getting
our troops out of Syria and then an
official behind the backs of the
American people lies to the president to
keep troops on the ground in a foreign
country we did not declare war on that
person is a traitor to this country that
person is committing seditious
conspiracy amen and is actively engaged
in a foreign I mean the amount of laws
that were violated it is it's not even a
question and this is fact we know that
happened there is so when I say the
banality of evil what you are saying is
you know what I just don't know let the
evil people keep doing their thing and
I'm like bro we can outright see there's
a guy who is obstructing the will of the
people that and the duly elected
president to serve out his term and end
a foreign war we did not want and you're
like I don't know we might want to keep
him give me the guy's name no no let's
put it this way the executive branch
serves at the pleasure of the president
that is what it actually says they serve
at the pleasure of the president so now
they're his staff these executive branch
and the people that work there are his
staff would you would you come and like
keep a whole bunch of people who maybe I
would say 80 you're are known to be uh
to object to your policies would you
just clean house and hire your own staff
right and kill that deep State that's
been there for years would you know that
wouldn't you want to know them wouldn't
you want to know that they were on your
side and he has every right to do that
it's like if if you were to buy have
your own company Tim wouldn't buy a
media company even though it was all
lefties and say yeah you can all still
work here here you go
task and purpose newsguard certified 100
out of 100 top U.S official admits lying
to Trump on American troop levels in
Syria saying we were always playing
Shell Games to not make clear to our
leadership how many troops we had there
it's insane treason yep what happened to
this guy nothing nothing ever and this
is exactly what we're talking about this
guy should be criminally charged yeah
you are being exact this is we should be
exact if we're talking about firing
people in the federal government Donald
Trump is not going to stand up with a
half an hour's time and say uh I'd like
to give you a list of every single
person needs to be fired here we go
starting in alphabetical order that's
insane well the reason so when when we
have this conversation and then Trump
addresses it and then a week later we
have another conversation but another
corrupt official and we have a
conversation Who's Who uh who's the guy
who lied before Congress about spying on
the American people uh James Clapper did
hey he should be in jail he should have
been so charged when when that when that
story happens
we go hey that's that guy's bad
and then Trump says I agree we should
arrest these people then we have another
story here this guy he's bad we should
arrest that guy yeah he committed a
crime then with a half an hour standing
at a Podium Trump's got a short amount
of time to explain his plans he says
we're going to go after these people
we're going to obliterate the Deep State
he's talking about this I hope what do
you mean you hope it's literally what
he's been talking about
think he's going to go after who are you
worried for in the Deep State
specifically refers to the corrupt
individuals like I don't think
corruption it's just it really does no
so why is it why is it that we get
swatted 15 times and there's no action
taken none wait where are the multiple
agencies to deal with the fact that
across Federal now I wonder but why did
so many FBI agents go and investigate a
garage poll rope for no reason for no
reason see the issue is the Deep State
isn't every single FBI uh agent the Deep
state is many of them in fact depending
on who you want to ask you go back to
Hoover the Deep state may just be
literally the whole agency but there are
a lot of people in the FBI who have
actually done things that go after child
exploitation we've seen that I like that
stuff Stop Those Predators but you know
what the problem is right now you have
uh I don't know uh we get swatted 15
times nothing garage poor hope
investigated Donald Trump criminally
charged Hillary Clinton not criminally
charged Joe Biden not criminally charged
this is the Deep state
and I have actually talked to people who
work in the intelligence agencies
uh and I've asked them what's it like is
it really that bad you know they say to
me they said it's exactly the same on
the inside as it is in the on the
outside a lot of good people who are too
scared to speak up because their bosses
are woke and they're scared they're
going to get fired or something bad is
going to happen and I'm like this is the
problem you've got core elements of
corrupt individuals who are deranged
cultists who are like we must imprison
Trump no matter what lying about what
Trump has done pushing these lies
relentlessly and refusing to criminally
charge anybody else hey you don't want
to arrest Hillary Clinton fine how can
you then turn around and go after Trump
for something that's not even as bad as
smashing phones with hammers and using
bleach bit a software to purge the hard
drive so no data could ever be recovered
a a clear violation of public records
law thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time